i'm sure that this is going to resonate
with people this conversation um do you
have suggestions for people who might be
feeling that kind of like
i know what you mean when you do
something that you're like your soul
doesn't agree with and it's like i call
it i think what i get is some sort of
existential horror
it's just like yeah it's just like
everywhere it's like you're going in the
wrong direction of reality or something
so if
if people are stuck in that
and are
scared how how do those people try and
stop and switch to going in the right
direction hopefully that made us some
semblance of sense right right and you
know what michaela i wish there was a
you can imagine that i get asked that
question
hundreds of times
and i think we want a simple answer
don't we we we want just one answer
that
i i don't think there's one answer um
part of it is to
to
try to listen to what you say
to what you're saying and see if it
makes you feel stronger or weaker yeah
like each word is like a stepping stone
through a swamp
you know and and if it's the right word
then you step on it it feels
secure and stable compared to the
territory around it and you test that
out
and you dare to
see if that's the way you think as
opposed to that persona that you're
putting on for public adulation and
protection
right that's the temptation of the actor
so in in the movie pinocchio when
pinocchio is trying to stop lying and to
become a real boy
he faces two major temptations apart
from lying
one is to
be a victim
and the other is to be an actor
it took me a long time to to figure out
why being an actor was a temptation
but you put your finger on it with your
description
it's to adopt a set of rules that will
well appeal to narcissistic inflation
something like that it's
it's there's a terrible totalitarian
danger in that
it's terrible
yeah so yes and and that's my suspicions
are that's what you were reacting to so
viscerally that you were participating
in that and you had your reasons but
um you mentioned something that i think
maybe the three of us could discuss that
would be
interesting
you know this idea about
all white people being racist
so
so i kind of wondered about that as a
psychologist but more broadly
because maybe you could say
well are all people
racist and here's here's what i mean by
that
well we all have an in-group preference
now what that group might be you know it
might be you and the person you love
might be you and your family might be
you in your town it might be you and
your state or your country it might be
you and your race you know that who that
in group is can vary
but
we do have preferences for people and we
do have in-group preferences and the
corollary of that is that we have
out-group
uh skepticism and maybe fear and maybe
disgust and all of that and
from what i've been able to understand
anthropologically that's more or less a
human universal you know as
as different peoples have been brought
around the world into
global
community let's say
one of the things that anthropologists
have found is that it's it's almost
always the case that
any given tribe of people will use the
word that refers to human beings to
their tribe
and some other word to everyone else
and so
it's possible that that's a deep
tendency that we all have to fight
against and i mean there's part of the
reason these ideas are so compelling to
people and able to possess them the
wokeness ideas let's say to use a
casual category is that
you know
they contain an element of truth
people have it in group preference
that can easily be distorted into
something that's that's quite akin to
racism i mean you even see that in
chimpanzees for example they'll go on
raiding
forays into neighboring territories and
if they outnumber the males do this if
they outnumber
the
foreigners that they come across they
will tear them to pieces
so it's yeah yeah that was a stunning
discovery
lovely that primatologists made jane
goodall's team [ __ ] discovered that in
the 70s it was a real shock
right so they were trying to find all
the nice chimps yeah well they were like
oh they just rip each other down to
shreds whoa okay yeah exactly well no
one had had any inkling
previous to that that that human
tendency for for war
you know
broadly speaking was so deep that it was
even shared by our you know closest
animal
uh
relative so this is very deep so you
know the idea that racism
and in-group preference all of that is
something that human beings struggle
with is true and then you say well
you know you twist out of it you say
well that's particularly true of white
people because they hold the power
it's like well you know it's an
interesting proposition
but the question is well
if it's true exactly how it's how is it
true and what's its limits and
you know how does that play out in the
case of other
races or groups asians for example right
um
and what are the dangers of putting the
idea that way like and
what makes you so sure that that's also
not true of your group and
how does power play into that like these
are all these are all genuine questions
that we should be asking ourselves
instead of
like hammering home the idea that we
have the answer to this it's like well
you know
you you you you said you know you you
got elevated as a black woman
in this well it's very difficult to see
that
to not see that as an exacerbation of
your in-group preference and then an
exaggeration of that implicit or
explicit racism on your part and i think
that's part of what you were rebelling
against yes yes yes yes
and and you know what the
questions that you were just asking
before those are the exact questions
that i had just simple questions
um
and it started to signal again that
something wasn't right here that i
couldn't even just ask the simplest
questions or at least felt that i
couldn't i could have
but i was much more scared of the
consequences of asking the questions
then leading with the curiosity of
getting some kind of answer right
um
and in my letter michaela you read this
pot out earlier about
the disempowerment of black people
that's how i started to feel extremely
disempowered you know even when people
would say things like yeah it's because
white people have all the power
according to who and in what context are
we talking about
which one is the world you are which
ones
right i had
i had an experience like that um
not
exactly like that it was like that but
for me and i was taking sciences um
because i'd switched out of humanities
because there was a lot of you know i
was taking a course on homer and it was
homer through the feminist lens and i
was like that's not what i came that's
how i paid you guys for so i switched
into sciences and about every couple
months somebody would come in and they'd
say okay for all the women in the room i
know you've had you've had a much harder
time getting to where you are than the
men have
and i was just like are you
are you telling me i'm stupid like what
exactly are you saying here and how dare
you suggest that it was just it was like
insulting in kind of a condescending way
which was the complete opposite of
whatever they were well maybe it wasn't
the opposite of what they were trying to
do
but
yeah it's condescending and irritating
yeah well it makes me make well think
about what that does in some sense it
makes your generic femininity
and your generic vulnerability
far more important
than your individual particularity
you know and this is what i've been
objecting to with regards to this
group mentality from the beginning it's
it it seems to me that it's
fundamental danger
the fundamental danger is the
devaluation of the
of the sacredness of the individual as
the primary category you replace that by
group identity you have no idea what
kind of devil you're messing with or
maybe you do to some degree you
experienced it a bit because you messed
about with that devil and you got
tempted and 7 000 people told you you
were right it's like imagine you're a
political leader
okay now imagine 30 million people tell
you that you're right and they chant
that in a mob
and they do that everywhere you go
because that's what happened in germany
and then you play to the crowd
you're that actor you play to the crowd
and you get hungry and hungrier for that
validation
and you train yourself to say anything
the crowd demands no matter how dark
right right
right